Carlos y Tamara
viven a la misma distancia de su trabajo
y comenzaron a caminar hacia
allá al mismo tiempo.
Ambos caminaron con una velocidad constante aunque no necesariamente igual
La distancia de Carlos al trabajo en diversos momentos se muestra en la tabla a continuación
Aquí tengo el tiempo,
aquí tengo el 50 segundos
después de que empezó a caminar,
100 segundos... 150 segundos....
Y aquí tenemos la distancia de Carlos a su trabajo,
medida en metros.
A los 50 segundos de haber empezado a caminar,
está a 830 metros,
a los 100 segundos estaba a 760
y a los 150 segundos estaba a
690 metros.
¿Cuáles de los siguientes enunciados
pueden ser verdaderos?
Selecciona todos los que apliquen.
Me dan todos estos enunciados de aquí,
vamos a ver de qué tratan.
Tamara vive a 830 metros de su trabajo
y caminó hacia él a 2 metros por segundo.
Tamara vive a 900 metros de su trabajo
y caminó hacia él a siete quintos de metro por segundo.
y caminó hacia él
a cinco séptimos de metro por segundo.
Y así son todas las opciones,
todas parecen hablar de la distancia a la que Tamara vive del trabajo
y a la velocidad con la que camina al trabajo.
Bueno, pues veamos qué sabemos.
Sabemos que Carlos y Tamara viven a la misma distancia de su trabajo,
viven a la misma distancia de su trabajo
y comenzaron a caminar
hacia allá al mismo tiempo.
O sea que si puedo encontrar la distancia
a la que Carlos vive de su trabajo,
puedo averiguar
la distancia a la que Tamara vive su trabajo.
Lo que quiero hacer es calcular,
¿cuál es la distancia de Carlos a su trabajo
cuando el tiempo "t" está en 0 segundos?
Para ello vamos a calcular la velocidad,
supongamos que,
medimos este intervalo,
pasamos de 50 a 100 segundos, es decir,
aumentamos en 50 segundos.
Nuestro aumento es de 50 segundos,
entonces,
a esto corresponde un cambio de qué distancia,
pues pasó de estar a 830 metros,
a 760 metros de su trabajo.
lo cual tiene sentido,
Carlos está caminando hacia el trabajo.
Pero bueno de 830 a 760,
significa que hay un cambio de
-70 metros.
Por lo tanto, la velocidad
con la que Carlos está caminando a su trabajo
es de 70 metros cada 50 segundos
y lo podemos verificar veamos.
Aquí otra vez pasaron 50 segundos...
han pasado 50 segundos
y acá de nuevo se corresponde con
una disminución de 70 metros en la distancia.
Por lo tanto,
¿a qué distancia vive Carlos de su trabajo?
pues como camina por velocidad constante,
50 segundos antes de estos 50 segundos,
tendría que estar 70 metros más lejos.
Por lo tanto a los 0 segundos,
Carlos estaba a
900 metros de su trabajo,
y noten que es consistente,
si empiezo en 0, pasan 50 segundos
y estoy a 830 metros del trabajo,
tal como tenía antes.
Por lo tanto,
Tamara también debe vivir a 900 metros de su trabajo
y eso me permite descartar esta opción.
Porque Tamara no vive a 830 metros
tampoco vive a 760
y tampoco vive de nuevo, a 830.
Pero ¿qué hay de esta? Tamara vive a
900 metros de su trabajo y camino hacia él
a siete quintos de metro por segundo.
Pues esto es perfectamente posible,
no tengo nada información
acerca de la velocidad de Tamara,
porque me dicen que
no necesariamente es igual a la de Carlos
pero no puedo descartar esta posibilidad
esto es enteramente posible.
Tamara vive a 900 metros de su trabajo
y camino hacia él a 5 séptimos de metro por segundo.
De nuevo, no puede descartar esta posibilidad,
no tengo información de la velocidad,
pero solo importa esto es enteramente posible.
Así que esas dos son las opciones correctas.